In this video, we
demonstrate that it's
possible to analyze cardiac
pulse from regular videos
by extracting the imperceptible
motions of the head caused
by blood flow.
Recent work has enabled
the extraction of pulse
from videos based on
color changes in the skin
due to blood circulation.
If you've seen
someone blush, you
know that pumping
blood to the face
can produce a color change.
In contrast, our
approach leverages
is perhaps more
surprising effect.
The inflow of blood doesn't
just change the skin's color.
It also causes the head to move.
This movement is too small to
be visible with the naked eye,
but we can use video
amplification to review it.
Believe it or not, we
all move like bobbleheads
with different motions
at our heart rate,
but at a much smaller
amplitude than this.
Now, you might wonder
what causes the head
to move like this?
In each cardiac cycle,
the heart's left ventricle
contracts and injects blood
at high speed to the aorta.
During the cycle,
roughly 12 grams of blood
flow to the head from the
aorta by the carotid arteries
on either side of the neck.
It is this influx of blood that
generates a force on the head.
Due to Newton's third law, the
force of the blood on the head
equals the force of the
head acting on the blood,
causing a reactionary,
cyclical head movement.
To demonstrate this process,
we coded a toy model
using a transparent mannequin
head, where rubber tubes stand
for simplified arteries.
Instead of pumping blood,
we will pump compressed air
provided by this air tank.
And I can release the
air using this valve.
Now, watch what
happens as I open
and close the valve
once a second,
similar to a normal heart rate.
Ready?
Here.
This motion is fairly similar
to the amplified motion
of real heads that
we've seen before.
We exploit this
effect to develop
a technique that
can analyze pulse
in regular videos
of a person's head.
Our method takes an input
video of a stationary person
and returns a one-dimensional
signal corresponding
to the head motions.
From this signal, we can
extract an average pulse rate,
as well as beat locations
for deeper clinical analysis.
We begin by locating the
face using a face detector
and selecting feature
points within the area.
The feature points
are tracked from frame
to frame of the video using
the Lucas-Kanade tracking
algorithm.
We use the vertical,
or y component,
of each of the feature point
trajectories for our analysis.
Next, we temporally
filter the signals
through a pass band
encompassing a normal pulse
range, while excluding
extraneous motions
like respiration.
We decompose the
multi-dimensional motion
of the head described
by the trajectories
into submotions using Principle
Component Analysis, or PCA.
PCA returns the main directions
along which the head moves.
We project the motion of
the head onto each component
and choose the signal with the
clearest dominant frequency.
We use the dominant frequency
to obtain an average pulse rate.
Finally, we perform peak
detection on the chosen signal
to obtain beat locations
for further analysis,
such as heart rate variability.
We tested our method on
different people varying
in skin tone and gender and were
able to get nearly exact pulse
rates compared to an ECG device.
In addition, our method
produced similar beat length
distributions to the ECG,
an exciting result that
shows that we can capture
more subtle information
about the heart than
just an average rate.
Finally, our method is robust
to different views of the head.
We obtained a pulse
from a sleeping newborn,
from the back of
a subject's head,
and even when a person
is wearing a mask.